bro here yall go with this CL chat chill
with all this PL 500 big 500 from GQ
hold on everybody clap y big 500 from g
y y' a never seen no 500 like that y'all
want want me to do the top T bro we
could do that yo GQ we could do that all
you gotta do hit me up just hit me up we
on that come on bro we on that bro we on
that bro I'm on that bro I swear I'm on
that bro what's up GQ I'm fan and these
are my 10
Essentials everything I do like from the
moment I open my eyes in the morning
till they go to sleep is content this is
what I do I really like I live this you
feel me this is not a part time anything
this is everything you feel me yo Vin I
PL you know what I'm saying me and here
we shoot you know I mean straight
movies you know what I'm saying
and then C not here CES be he edit that
he make that come to life
shooting on my own I was weird at first
like I didn't want to give nobody the
camera like no I was like on something
like nah bro I ain't believeing that I
had to hold my like this but one
day I was like this like
camera yeah let me try something
different and like he held it and then
we just started doing like it was
just like I could move freely nothing in
my hands but the content was still being
recorded I was like yo this is a whole
different ball
game car keys bro this everything is
documented bro like we really came from
nothing so we started off walking you
know what I'm saying I got pictures on
my Instagram I started off walking then
you got uh I moved on to the Honda Cod
that was my first like baby you know
your first car is like it's a Lambo it's
not a Lambo it's a Lambo to you you know
what I'm saying V6 my music car so you
know that 3:00 4 in the morning the
chuch cetto bumping and it's going crazy
that's me stop calling the cops on us
I'm going to drive away so we be like
this like and then the music be right
here so you got to like put up like the
little sound a little bit the base and
just you know we just be
vibing and all that listen everybody in
New York you know the song but you don't
know who sing it shout out to bro we be
going through my BMW M4 you feel me it's
the Green Goblin if you know you know
the Green Goblin bro you know what I'm
saying it's been a low ke out of
retirement he don't be going crazy no
more like that but if he got to show out
he will and we got the Escalade Cadillac
you know what I'm saying it's the big
body I like going everywhere with this
you know what I'm saying I feel like I'm
floating literally though if I want some
power Lamborghini Earth big dog you know
what I'm saying got the wide body on it
purple look like Barney I don't know my
next toy it got to be like Oh either
either an Aventador or um or the or the
sf90 Ferrari one of those two bro that's
that's like Exotics right there that's
crazy my next essential is a big ass
[Music]
fridge
damn and I don't really do the healthy
but these all right I ain't going
to lie he all right man why you put a G
man I said top 10 Essentials what are
you talking about it makes sense right
it's essential bro it's part of
life Chris if you watching Chris look at
us when you order your your OCT and she
disrespectful you know that your EXT is
going to hit extra like it's like oh no
yes you know what I'm saying life is
just it's
just different feel me with the Arizona
mango if you want to switch it up as I
said you want to be on your Healthy
but I respect it get on your water
we got the chop cheese on the hero you
know what I'm saying oh my God you know
like if you know you know bro it's a lot
for the morning time but nowadays the
New York teams be having I be seeing
them with coffees and in the
morning what's going on y stressed out
some all right get you a little
chop cheese you be all right man you
know saying be all right
my Dominicans outside
man look at this right here let me show
you something you know you know what the
itis is it's a put you to sleep I'm
telling you this right here you know
everybody spam different in the chat
different with some different you know
what I'm saying Bey you know what I'm
saying we was missing the coke this all
though but if you know you know facts if
you got the rice and beans and
everything you know you got to get the
you feel me plao it's really plantains
but like sweet and it's soft you know
what I mean and with the fork it just
like butter like you want some spizzle
you know what I'm saying
Saratoga don't worry about it it happens
part of life know I mean it's cool
look when you on your Healthy Vibe you
do this the oranges the mini oranges and
stuff like that you can peel them all
day stays under your under your nails
and stuff ah whatever nobody cares I've
been losing weight for 3
years let's put that is it working I
don't know but we hey we do we do what
we can y'all thought it was over yall
thought I was done I'm never done I got
another fridge it's part of life man
bring it in bring it in I got the other
fridge I can't even show you what's in
it though but just know it's really my
central you got to have a fridge what's
the F tax what's that about so the tax
is pretty much you know what I'm saying
feed your friends people people confuse
it like you got to take food from your
friend but I'm just saying feed your
friend bro you know what I'm saying
sometimes 5% sometimes 10 what do y'all
that's what you know I'm not even going
to say nothing bro but just know bro
that's the tax bro that's that's pretty
much the tax feed the peoples
bro so I always wanted to go y bag you
know what I'm saying um I don't know I
seen like everybody who I feel like is
fly I want to be fly so everybody who I
feel like was fly and still fly just go
yall Daisy so in my bag I keep my laptop
um cuz this how I make my mon you know
what I'm saying I need my laptop uh with
my laptop you got to have your mouse cuz
I don't like doing the trackpad stuff I
got to use my little mouse U my phone
dying Chargers in here ready to go at
all times we got the ski mask the ski
mask is like uh not for any illegal
activities it's just I don't know I'll
be in the airport and it be I get to be
like lowkey for a little bit at least at
least I think I'll be lowkey for a
little bit and yeah pretty much
it this some fire where I bought I
think I bought this in Japan sto over
like this you feel me it's some cool
like it's just swaggy as like
I love it this right here is like my
first bus down you know what I'm saying
shout out to KC me and K you know what
I'm saying bust down rly Al you know
what I'm saying like this is when we
first got the bust downs and that's
where that really really came from
we really just like yeah we got to get
the bus down Ries bro it's my gold piece
you know what I'm saying I'm Dominican
and Dominicans love gold so we be
throwing this on you know what I'm
saying thinking I don't know who who we
be thinking we are bro you know what I'm
saying we be throwing it on you know I'm
saying you got the Rope I like laying my
rope chains you know what I'm saying you
got my I barely wear my grills these are
my grills uh I even forgot who made them
but shout out to him he's he's good uh
this my first big chain in my opinion
you feel me it's the Phantom chain I
wear the Phantom one first cuz it came
first you know what I'm saying but
then I wear the A&P
one on top cuz a& on top you feel me I
never was going to get inter chains uh
but then like my first chain
uh Kai it's my brother he was like come
on BR you got to get a chain bro come on
win him he kept saying that over and
over I was going to get a w instead of a
f I'm like I'm going to give my actual
name uh this the ri playing
Jane I keep it in this box cuz you know
that's his that's his his
home prey stuff like that so Drake said
my youngest richer than you rappers in a
all streamers real life like not trying
to be weird but I don't know why they
keep trying to make the Stream is like
we I don't know what's up with y'all
like we don't bother nobody we just do
our own thing bro we just be living life
having fun and be we be on the game bro
just chopping it up eating good mukbang
all type of bro be lit you
need to pull it to the stream bro stop
being
weird a by any means possible you feel
me by any means possible who's a part of
the group you got Duke K myself agent
Chris and Davis you feel me that's the
six members we got beautiful team let
clap it up for the beautiful team you
feel me f you know what I'm saying F we
be doing our thing bro every day twitch
YouTube Tik Tok Snapchat Instagram it
don't matter we're there trying to get a
house the first time was crazy cuz Duke
you know he older than us he was like
bro y'all think I'm about to move it to
a crib but with time though it we did it
once you move in with somebody you find
out oh you put your socks on like this
or you throw you know what say you find
out the weirdest yo what up that's you
though but as long as you openminded and
realize you know everybody different
it's
okay shout out to my phone music is O
like it can change your whole vibe it
change your whole mood it can change how
you feel that day like you could Sho you
could choose your Vibe you could that
ass choose how you want to feel today
when it come to music though I be
playing all type of stuff though like
everything my most recent so I've been
playing the Drake album TS I love TS she
just dropped me and you i' been i' been
like every day I bump TS every day
that's my Central for real temps you got
to bump temps feel me it's good for the
soul you got um Bad Bunny I I bump o SP
music by you feel
me um I just came back from the UK so
I've been buing M Central C and K
trapping them so they go crazy it's just
a lot you feel me sh I even got some
sharing in this like for real I
just love music
[Music]
facts so my next essential is Bliss
X and uh my
clones it's going to take me a little
while I'm not going to
lie how you like what you put on is very
important all
right my bad I smell good know I mean I
don't believe in like men and women
clones I I put on a lot of women clones
it's how you rock it bro it's like can
you pull it off um right now my favorite
though this one like of all time of all
of all time either this
one damn this one is like my my most one
of my most recent pickups I don't know
why but this this if I want like this
one you got different seasons for
different if you know you know it's a
lot I don't like to get too deep into it
cuz then it starts messing up your head
this is my my I love this in the morning
for some reason just feel fresh Bliss X
okay can't be chapped up out there you
know what I'm saying people like carmx
um I like blissx you know what I'm
saying just real quick you know what I
mean so I buy like 10 pack and I lose
all 10 and I buy 10 more I never finish
them I never
finished this ever and last but not
least yall say Vapor up I say vapo you
know what I mean you put this on you
sick I'm a little sick right there I
might throws on my chest and stuff like
that you know what I'm saying it just
you wake up a new person and after hour
you going to be you can smell everything
bro just it opens up everything bro you
could use this for anything you listen
you limping put this on bro you feel
sick put this on bro your head hurt put
this on bro like you going to be all
right trust me you going to be all
right I take mental health real serious
cuz I ain't going to lie I remember
being like messed up like well at least
I thought I was messed up I was just
going through but like everybody go
through sometimes be getting
overlooked you know what I'm saying and
everybody got their battles and that's
why I treat everybody with respect and
I'm always like trying to be on some
happy cuz like be going
through like we go through stuff
bro we go through it's it's
great to address it it's great to like
attack ah head on and try to get to the
root of it and what's going on and why
you feel the way you feel you feel me um
and once you start taking those baby
steps you'll look back and be like damn
that was me and I don't even know how I
got
here uh these right here I never knew
how to pronounce them so I'm going to
try today I think it's called Su Co or S
I don't know they hard like they they
not even expensive and they just slip
on I'll be right back cuz I ain't going
to lie for me to explain this whole
thing y going have to give you a second
see cuz the way I live my life is a
little different like you know what I'm
saying I live my a little different
my bad y'all so what I was saying was
like when it comes to the sliding and
just the clothing and stuff you feel me
um it just I like to buy stuff that not
everybody got but um you know like it
just it just stand out it just like you
see these and you going to be like nah
like they hard but where you got them
from you know me stuff like that but I
might go and get me some um what's some
other like I get stuff from Twitter
people random designers they put they
post their link online and I if I like
it I'm buying it I don't really go by
brand I go by what I like but some
people send me some real cool
stuff this good as bro like
the rice is just o hold on y but yeah
though that's my uh that's pretty much
my top 10 Essentials right there you
know what I'm saying shout out to GQ all
that good stuff and uh you know what I
mean I'm going leave with my plate and
I'm all at y respectfully
though